hello welcome to the lobby gamespot's
weekly hang it right here on gamespot
com on youtube.com forward slash
gamespot if you're watching this on
demand I'm your host Daniel Dwyer and
boy do we have a show today joined to my
right mr. Christopher waters haha wait
your turn hey wait there's Oreos furless
first I and these guests have to just
leave it's already gone bad should we
start again yeah don't worry about it
takes a comparison to my show this is
your show up Danny what's on today's
show done to Tim guys over here there
doesn't miss me what are we going to
talk about in your on your show today
send coffee it really crappy coffees in
the third floor here's the coffee it's
not official we branded outlets a hand
rose is it we're in cooperation with
them they're not actually officially
part of us don't I drink this no no but
that's the announcement for later we're
gonna talk we've got a big announcement
later that's them [ __ ] spill the
beans it's early that's a good coffee
right right right right we shopped that
earlier today about games and broken age
broken age that's a game but back in
came out last year no no only the first
half the first half second half of
coming out today today a right now if
you're in North America a funeral it's
tomorrow it's something like that yet
isn't it already tomorrow in your I
actually he's right that's all I did it
time travel it is already tomorrow he's
right but that's Australia or something
oh no no I guess it knows world in ok
confuse their like point five of our
demographics that we don't acknowledge
Australia I'm game scramble we have an
Australian office which actually makes
it kind of awkward they acknowledge them
I'm sorry down under hey broken age yeah
axiom I'm good to get out of the system
all done it's like a real good I would
say a real good poop because you get an
assistant I don't want to imply like
that how does it feel to have it out
there you guys get on the toilet for
three years yes if the game is better
than that the motion is better but it is
as satisfying I really the most
successful at toilets kickstarter in the
history is it actually still the most
did what no it wasn't in time hey I
think Brian Brian game made more
afterwards ours was the best yes yeah
and they got a lot of tension and then
we made a documentary you didn't why
have you seen that no documentaries up
for free in our YouTube channel you guys
create more document
reason we do is watch us pretty much all
the time yes it's like there's more
hours of us just sitting there talking
people at work watch it and they're
watching themselves in a meeting to have
a meeting and then the watch the episode
of themselves in a meeting in the room
they're watching the episode in but it
still entertaining the impetus behind
all that stuff the two-player
productions right yeah it was was that
that was mostly born out of the sort of
extra goodies you wanted from the
Kickstarter right no it was the other
way around a they want to make a
documentary and they came down they said
because they had done a minecraft
documentary yes and they said do you
want to do documentary about a game I
was like yes because I love attention
and then they said well we should
probably kick start a game to to go
along with it so we don't have to deal
with a publisher saying you can't put
the bad parts in right so we did a kick
start doing and so we were able to like
control the whole thing and show all the
bad parts and then some bad parts
happened and we should hmm but hopefully
people watching it enjoyed watching
yourself is there like a bad parts
supercut that I can watch a chance you
if I just want to watch the bad parts
you can probably get a whole 20 minute
was the confirmation bias Carly staring
at each other in a meeting like what are
we gonna do we just split it into two
yeah does that mean but all's well that
ends well yeah and what that what's it
like yeah what's it like top about there
in the world map one last one it's fun
it's out to get it's out there getting
good reviews got a bunch of 90s out
there six couple degenerate less yeah I
don't actually I haven't actually seen
our review it's nice outside i wasn't
ready but you know luckily no credible
scientist and a lot of people when the
first one came out it's kind of like
that Walking Dead syndrome where which
isn't actually something they got a
disease read it bye bye Teej anak wife
it toward else ideas best called
grassroots marketing yeah they decided
to kind of hold off on playing the first
one so they could maybe no scared about
that yeah spoiler they could get any
review would have the spoiler it's
really a screenshot might spoil the
thing yeah there's a pretty don't people
like you play it now don't wait and then
when the director came has like okay you
should actually go back as far as the
beginning just to get all the hints and
stuff so that my recommendations are
really annoying do you think people
should watch play at all as one as one
because it wasn't you know
really meant to be split in half so
there's got a lot of like hints and
stuff in the first half that pay off in
the second half right we're really like
little hints in the dialogue and if we
made up previously on broken age it
would call so much attention to them you
know I've had I know how to solve this
puzzle now because of this previously
are there any like gags that you guys
have like set up a year early and then
hoping that they lament like dumb jokes
that are set up in the first half yeah
it's true I what am I to do decide that
it is easy to easy to play with if you
know all the puzzles you get sick when
did you guys just decide to split it
into the two because it does kind of
feel like an active one I Mac to not to
give away the sort of the real obvious
aspect of white feels like that but any
you lose during a meeting or we're
traffic or how we're gonna whether we're
going to cut the game just cut it down
and make it shorter and I really didn't
want to do that and then actually our
business guy was like what if you ship
the first half to pay for the second
half hmm and I was against it for a
while because people have to wait to get
this cliffhanger yeah resolved but it
turned out to be good I mean turned out
to help in that we released it and we
got a good reception from it and we
found out what characters people liked
or characters you know or what puzzles
they liked and didn't like it were able
to kind of incorporate that into the
second yeah the second act was already
gonna be like harder the first one just
because it's later in the game but we
were able to kind of feel like we had
permission to make it harder because the
people who play the first actress I hope
it's harder I'm really even harder oh
yeah our anak my anecdotal evidence of
that is Mary Kish was playing it uh
early last week and I just see her
scribbling stuff down on paper and
getting vexed I was like I don't
remember having to write anything down
in the first half but I second i love it
we get the rights of slightly that map
you make it work when you're playing
Zork i was about to say in secret of
monkey island when I had to find the
bloody sword master the ladies you wrote
down the insults know that the actually
abuse later treasure map to get to the
to the other life right like yeah yeah
that one was a real like pen a paper bag
memory traces down do you know that you
get was like the hard hard puzzles not
so much Lacey reviewers
that was kind of your like return to the
the genre you if not what created but
sort of made some of the most was around
for ya I made something like the most
beloved games in I John what's it feel
like having a behind you now like that
you kind of dove back into this the
result for years people were talking
about like the death of adventure games
if is like for about two decades what
did it feel like what's it feel like now
to sort of have gone back major you're
the first one in a long time and to have
it done it was it was really eye-opening
cuz a lot i had made him for for so many
years i'd forgotten a lot about what
they're like that they you do a lot of
work for like ten minutes of gameplay so
you can work for three years and so
we'll get through it maybe 10 hours or
something like that and like so
basically like it you know they can
finish it and then sale what's next oh
yeah all rights make another one you
know so um but also reminding the good
parts of venture games the things you
like the opportunities for humor what
you can have in a lot of different games
but eventually games allow certain
pacing in a certain depth of character
that i think are really fun to craft
craft that's a craft as a verb oh yeah
i'm embarrassed you're a craft man this
one the master of your craft didn't say
author you taught her yeah oh yeah what
then yeah yeah how's Elijah Wood play
the game he has played Act one act two
he done a pre-release copy that yeah he
has a code that should have I just
actually treated him now to tell him
didn't play so hopefully of it is he
gonna do a review on Elijah Wood like Oh
what if he hates it oh god about
whatever like I did such a great
performance and these guys messed it up
in the editing room did you have to like
bring any of the voice actors back in
when you because presumably you'd
actually like yeah recorded before but
before we had to bring him back for a
second a second goes it pickups or was
it everything like did you have like a
lot of Act two already there that you
would already look really I mean jack
black we recorded his all his stuff in
the first half everyone else had an act
one session and Mac to session so some
of them by the time they did the
accusation it played the game or knew a
lot more about what we were doing and
really fun because they they got into it
to me the fairest the one character we
had a little girl who kind of aged she's
like two years older which is oh you go
from like you go from she ciders pitch
like post yes exactly she sounds like
brenda vaccaro and high that's a
reference no one's gonna yeah he's under
from 40 okay well ambassador you box
what's he watching I don't know I was
talking about the Ravagers oka Sarah oh
yeah it's like old hey look at you look
in the rabbit ears Rob looking the
revenues you go liudmila are you looking
the rabbit atiba oh it's not like this
one area where is Robert ears grandma
hands aren't those are your hands change
the Robert ears haigo haigo do anymore
there what am I looking at the revenues
it aren't there that are actually over
there how many guys how many games of
you guys released this unit to something
done well again reactor creamer masters
uh broken age is brought out this bribe
me were gonna is that coming out yeah
yeah he's all busy with his baby yeah I
saw he's having a baby massive smile
terrified or just poor child the baby
yeah it's gonna have to grow into its
mouth it's good it's just like do you
know about babies meds like they they're
the same size their whole lives you grow
into the truth hey like baby Joker look
yeah okay no that's not true that yeah
there's a picture of them last week and
everyone is freaking out about it of the
back a lot of tattoos for an infant to
me sorry brah baby all right but not
watching this covered in poop and barf
right now what are you guys gonna work
on a message house he'll ship that and
that'll be awesome and secret thing Oh
secret secret things and we're not gonna
tell people we're working on anymore but
we promised everyone we had a secret
things unveiled was this wasn't my
secret thing we were hoping that maybe
if we like pressured you into it then
you could you know i'd like to make an
announcement but i don't have any oh
that's a shame day damn you know when it
cuts to you that you get a crouch behind
your face yeah oh yeah shoulder it's
just a crotch it's more it's the
codpiece yeah me any clients is another
word for it sure can we cut the Chris
can we get me in my team you do only
person to share for this a bit like five
minutes getting the camera off there is
ya know she's Lumia right now for a fact
but really this is just my constant
companion here on the show it's perfect
and I'm gonna put a little thought
bubble bloop bloop bloop
he's thinking about really buy a cod
yeah as Brotherhood of Steel am i right
heap you're the only person that's ever
noticed that you've said it multiple
times oh I noticed a constant yeah
everything I mean if you look at
pictures of yourself and crotches
prominently featured intends to other
cultures around me whenever I look at
now when you're born hmm it's know just
how much predator mask which actually
makes no sense whatsoever almost
hospital covering all over to it that
would have gone badly yeah first so yeah
any pictured me people are always drawn
to the crotch but for other reasons so
you guys kind of something maybe free
three or I'll get anything for you three
babies okay bees guys rising phoenix
yeah yeah the [ __ ] up with who clapped
your game you can't say sues that'd be
great over there we're driving audience
we got today yeah just a famous sports
person I see I see some reflect I see
reflective glasses back there and only
that I had the live audience component
here it's really who would ever do show
the live audio yeah it doesn't seem
smart yeah probably public grow we just
need a lot of positive reinforcement I
what updates about gang beasts okay and
they see they're doing they just a new
update and they hey what are the updates
about game bees Avengers costumes was
for oh yeah we'll be showing you what he
is 40 great which is awesome with move
support have you played it yeah please
later gonna be so right one violent
that's and Thomas the best game ever are
you guys gonna do the sports friend
things we're like two people can share
control or each get an analog stick and
then the buttons and triggers on one
side that is crazy yeah what's crazy I
got the bone low casa de boneless we're
just a helper here doesn't help we don't
tell them what to do we just play the
game we like it we're like um how can we
get a lot of free copy to this game
while we should and help them publish
its bum [ __ ] then we can play it all day
lovely fellows any two player production
stuff a backbone off amazing okay
they're what they're based in the UK
right oh the base in UK yes derivation
Sheffield Sheffield should I say the
name of the town they're in oh no
enemies have been looking for other
creditors no there no there Dave they be
there upstanding fellows I'm sure they
wouldn't mind us saying they're inch of
him just give their address right now if
you want yeah so send your love letters
to actually no addresses and Englanders
will be like like blue house
she liked his name's yes give like a
name of the house and everyone's
supposed to just know where I had a
friend in a town over from me that was
the only town called this thing I'm just
gonna call it's a boat strand for the
sake of argument all its Jenna he had
like Patrick McCarthy boat strand
Ireland and male would get to her first
his name in the town yeah it's we go to
Schaefer thank very much going on but so
fast congratulate I mention broken age
you did it's awesome we talked about of
the moment I mention crotch sure did we
manage to talk you had your whole time
without any spoilers go play bro can I
Drive it is that on steam oh it's almost
a seaborne exposition for invita and
it's on android and iOS is across boy
it's on the ps4 and Vita is cross bike
ride safe is quad-core save as well Yeah
right all right on everything else is
cross save across even we use Dropbox
you can like cross save between your
everything great and if you lose your
save just email timid mi and walk you
through it Tim Schafer San Francisco
California yeah we are doing a thing
later so I talked about the thing later
Gregor not sure we're doing we're doing
actually like the old lucasarts hit line
you call we bought of know about a phone
we're gonna put a balm over people call
for hints is it gonna cost like ten
dollars a minute yeah but it's an
assistant is a bail in the cash later
okay Tim I hey and so just go clam tower
whatever in Ireland Tommy yeah sure yeah
alright that's enough from clamtxt.com e
but we'll be back in a second first of
all we have a trailer for a game what is
it Mary Brooke Paige Brooke it's not is
it broken age we sent you it's not it's
something else check it out
Just Cause 3 pre-order now to secure the
exclusive weaponized vehicle back coming
holiday 2015 hello welcome back to the
lobby a new Call of Duty is coming out
this year would you believe it mr. Chris
waters and Rob handlery you guys played
it black ops 3 and they tease that out
really badly there for a while as if
everyone didn't realize was black ops 3
short on the media dead set and you guys
went down to the Star Wars majigger and
some reason they were also showing call
of duty well we had to go five across
the breadth of LA to get there but yet
okay because right York okay so let me
know what's going on black ops 3 getting
even close as if titanfall call of duty
we're closing off you're just trying to
merge them back together ok this is I'm
pehle we'll see you back home soon
enough what's going on now now
titanfall's got that wall running that
momentum thing going on and advanced
warfare is over here with the like
kittens this way look really quickly
yeah what if we just right in the middle
somewhere yeah but this one straight up
godlike water running and popping around
and jet pack stuff again yes so it's got
traversal stuff basically there's like a
thrust jump and it's like it can use it
you can use it like a double jump but
it's like a double jump with an energy
bar so it's it's a controlled metered
thing right and you can kind of go left
and right it's all I got me afloat yeah
like yes if you're like you're tapping
write you up and you tap the sort of
float yeah um but the main thing that I
kind of took away was like it's a
traversal fluidity thing we're no longer
you like constantly like pushing a to
climb a wall and all the stuff it's like
your initial jump and then as long as
you're facing in the direction of where
you trying to go you just kind of flew
in there you just waste clamber through
so you you know you clear easily clamber
over a windowsill and even now backwards
you can move backwards and do it as well
as have your gun all the way they're
always up yeah this week so how does it
feel how what how different does it feel
to advance water so it feels I mean and
this was the bank chair the drum track
was banging the whole time we were there
is that fluidity is that guns up thing
and it does feel more fluid I mean you
feel like you have a certain kind of
flow through
the the map and the distinction I drew
with titanfall and advanced warfare was
titanfall you're sort of moving in
concert with the map whereas in advanced
warfare you're sorted you're just
darting around the map within your own
little like abilities you don't really
have to necessarily know which how long
this wall extends and whether it curves
in order to like successfully navigate
it yeah so it's a little bit more of
that environmental awareness and that
like you know just moving around the map
is not only like a stunt in of itself
but also kind of satisfying so it's not
as if you're like because the thing in
sight involve is very much like you have
to get from the spawn point to where the
action is we're going to try and make it
as quick as possible if you do that
right this is the lane so is it less
it's less about like covering large
pieces of ground no this is still call
of duty sighs maps so like even if
you're just running you know normally
you're going to get into the action very
quickly and then you know they've got
also got this sort of like power slide
which just dashes you forward in a slide
position and a couple other in like
they're swimming now but yeah so needed
you know yeah it definitely still feels
I mean there you see the titanfall shot
yeah right and like while running and
shooting dudes is still just Cristobal
did it didn't make it means it's not
cool for other people to do it and it's
still fun to do but yet there is that
kind of fluidity that is a nice contrast
to the abrupt and horrible death that
often before yes you in call duty ok so
you guys played it for a little while
obviously this is super early games on
for another six months at least we'll
probably see a lot more at e3 just
before we wrap it up what are your sort
of initial impressions of this in
comparison to last year's rob was
renting about this you preferred to
advanced warfare yeah i mean i am i
suppose my play style goes like i just
love being frantic and running around
which is why titanfall and advanced
warfare were pretty appealing but this
is the ISIS it's more to tone down its
not as like glitchy right like Vance
warfare is always like these combo moves
and being taken on by surprise this felt
a lot more like let's prolong the fight
like there's for instance other thing
they completely omitted was no longer
can I stab you once with a knife like if
we're close enough
yeah it's a gun but as opposed to like
dying in social doesn't kids develop
male a yes vote what's basically push
back and like have some more phones oh
cool all right I like that yeah and I I
mean this is sort of this weird scenario
for me every years like I enjoy playing
call of duty at press events I get
psyched for it to release yeah I play it
at release for like a week yeah and then
I game on to something else where's you
played like titanfall involved for a
long time you play for months yeah it's
that's not my way with multiplayer
shooters in general yes it happens to be
with call of duty so I'm intrigued I
feel like it's sort of carving out a
distinct niche among this sort of the
trend of much more mobility in shooters
that we're seeing in the games we've
mentioned plus halo 5 etc etc I'm
excited to see where it where it lands
and how it feels but it seems promising
cool alright thanks gentlemen for
telling us all about that I'm sure we'll
have more impressions on the site over
the next couple of weeks all the way up
to e3 and welcome it back in a second
Peter Brown is writing up a bunch of
stuff about what's going on at Konami
we're gonna pull them out for a couple
of minutes and I briefly get a summary
of that we'll be back in just a minute
stick around so you all moved in uh no
not really well if your rooms close to
alexs you should be careful since she
snores like a truck you wouldn't think
it to look at her but it's like a
chainsaw fighting a pack of wolves can
we just stop talking about this yeah
what are we actually doing time
every year the seniors spend the night
on Edwards Island it's a kamina high
tradition everyone this is Jonas Alex's
new stepbrother from I already forgot
where yeah he's cool so be nice oh we
won't fight great cool somebody changed
the station what's so special about this
place the island was a military fort
it's a tourist trap for morons you
wanted by Christmas ornaments of World
War two threat Oh relax we'll have a
good time
come on let's explore hey what's that
see this siren pretty cool right yo why
would that
you
Kaname what's going on guys I mean
really you make some good games make
that soccer game it's almost as good as
the real good one you make that metal
gear solid game they're pretty great a
bit long-winded sometimes but they're
pretty awesome you got those pachinko
machines they're pretty fun they're okay
you got those got those gyms they got
like a set of gems as well I'm asking
you to peterbrown you got a set of Jim's
this a serious question yeah I got a set
of Jim like Kaname like Jim's we go and
you work out and everyone dresses up a
solid snake and lean your messy and they
work it it's not right Peter Brant
expert on all things Konami I guess yeah
that's my official title now yeah yeah
they got a bunch of health centers they
run a bunch of gambling stuff rent
pachinko it's okay they're they're
backing out of video games in a way that
is sort of unprecedented right so many
companies fold and they put out a press
release like well we're done forcing it
to leave people off the Japanese Way is
very different they tend to sort of hot
like mask this is like that mask the
fact that maybe things aren't going so
well is this because the nature of
Japanese business being that like
corporations like this have their
fingers in many pies as opposed to the
Western tradition of a business very
much being like in one sort of vertical
like Kaname is a very got a widespread
portfolios its kind of their unique but
I think you look at someone like Sony
then you can say they're not totally
unique in that regard yeah but I think
it has more to do with the the culture
in Japan things are handled differently
you're sure so do you think this is
Konami basically stepping away from
games in a sort of an intentional but
just maybe slightly protracted way
before we say that can we just list the
evidence real quick ya going what why we
are you thinking Kaname is getting out
of games in
way yeah so somebody that spoke to me on
record but anonymously you know he
basically laid down the groundwork for
everything that is sort of come out now
we are Kaname is pushed Kojima side he's
no longer an executive content officer
he's no longer even an official employee
he is a contractor a new Nami along with
other heads of the studio from Kojima
Productions which is now Konami Tokyo
yeah could you were productions name is
off the record there could you
productions LA which opened about a year
and a half ago is now Konami Los Angeles
really no more Fox with lightning legs
Yeah right retinol hold off the graphics
everything that's how everything started
right there removing all these this text
and you know a Hideo Kojima game was
gone he's one of the few developers out
there whose name is credited on buses
yeah you know I mean so of course people
are going to notice when that happens
and big and asked a lot of questions and
economies response to all these rumors
that we reported on was hey no he's
still working on the game and also we're
making a new metal gear and we're hiring
right now basically skirting around the
issue without denying it without
confirming it and placating fans who may
think oh no we're not going to get more
metal gear yeah but what Kaname is
missing when they say that for that end
assuming that's their goal is that
people don't just want new metal gear
they want a new metal gear game from
hideo kojima because metal gear is Hideo
Kojima and and so that's a big problem
and you know people were excited for
silent Hills because hey we love metal
gear but we've you know it's kind of
been the same story being told in
different chunks over the course of a
few decades and Silent Hill was a chance
for him to do something really really
new he brought in blood like caramel del
Toro hmm obviously who was very exciting
especially in that realm of horror and
the sort of dark fantasy and Konami to
pull the plug on that it's not
surprising given what i was told that
kojima yes he is a contractor but he's
also pissed and he's yeah you know he
wants to do right by probably his name
and also for the fans to finish metal
gear but work on work on silent Hills
hadn't actually begun it was still in
the planning on paper phases after PT
they were just heads down on phantom
pain still are yeah and so yeah and so
you know that's been cancelled and the
guy that I spoke with he you know a NASA
my son
initially his answer was well that's
between del Toro and Konami so that's
what I assumed was the deal yeah but del
Toro at this event this film event this
weekend said that he's really sad he
doesn't get to work on this game I don't
know if that's because he only would
have done it with Kojima I bet that's
part it sounds like that that was the
sort of the exciting part of that
relationship but I want what that was
yeah that was the impetus for the entire
project yes Robin hook that's the
exciting part of the relationship even
if kojima's leaving Konami I mean this
is a new opportunity for him and
presumably all his co-workers who are
also getting shuttle out the door yeah
to do something new it might not say
have metal gear solid in her name but
you still have that creativity pamida
yeah and there's so there are two
discussions here right there's the point
you bring up where it's like this frees
up Kojima to do something new and
exciting which I'm personally very
interested in yeah I think absolutely
anyone who appreciates the work he's
done should look forward to that because
he's not limited to just one series you
know from everything every evidence
we've seen over the years even that
serious has changed a lot and he's done
really interesting things with bed we
have every reason to hope and believe
that he'll be able to do something
creative and very interesting and unique
moving forward on the other hand you
have a company like Kaname who's been
around for a very long time is
responsible for publishing so many great
video game series but since the dawn of
the HD era it's just been on a CD clone
slave the holds on and and i just
realized today which was a surprise to
me but winning 11 pro evo makes more
money than metal gear no really Miller
solid has been on a decline well we'll
see if that even comes out this year
yeah sad times for Konami maybe
something will see from cause I'm on the
future fingers crossed peter brian thank
you so much for coming on yep talking to
spanish i will be back in just a second
in fact i think we need to roll a little
trailer a better than something
something before we get these oh this
one is this a thing i think this is
thing Danny it's a thing oh man is there
a thing happening huh roll the thing
dude all right guys here it is gamespot
see treats listen all right looks a
little bigger than last year's can I
bring my fancy lobby chair can't really
talk about video games on the internet
without my fancy lobby chair wait who's
this area over here for oh that's where
the kind of funny guys are gonna be
sitting on ice wait what dude they're
gonna eat all of our food yeah I mean
they are right now
you have any wings this June watch the
guy from kind of funny team up with
gamespot for the best III coverage of
all time watch the games watch stage for
demos of all the latest titles announced
at e3 2015 and watched the kind of funny
stage to watch the guys hang out with
the biggest names on the internet to
talk about everything happening at the
show that's two shows two streams
broadcast directly from the e3 show
floor into your eyeballs this coming
June check it out LA Convention Center
am i right things are happening I hope
they had asked for that for oh they
don't man [ __ ] them yeah oh my god Greg
Miller hey Danny a dancer I'm good how
are you Colin Moriarty good to see you
thank you very much back nah worries oh
yeah you want to hang out in most yeah
okay baby but everything together see
how many people we can shove into the
booth if that's what I really want to
see how many we got two stages how can
we out loud each other can I be so loud
on our stage that I ruined your stream
yep oh yeah probably yeah great do I not
had a couple of those faceoffs last year
and yeah i'm gonna kick it up a notch
yeah you had Neil druckmann we'll be
over there trying to tell you something
about it all right wow you're great
you're gonna have Cisco on your stay
right right now we have a soft commit
from Cisco that is Riley done on the guy
who did that thong song that is not a
joke like I we basically the woman when
you guys came to us and said do you want
to run second stage and do whatever you
want on it we are okay this is a chance
for us to hang out with all our dumb la
friends yeah so it's like we see the
video game in their own oh no wait you
didn't say that see you didn't say that
when you get a game of the dump truck
full of money that wasn't working caveat
cisco devon Sawa we're getting everybody
in there everybody you expected not to
expect all done hot current celebrity
okay
no in devon Sawa well video game people
in was very exciting a lot of people are
we're going a lot of people that
descends yeah great yeah it's gonna be
very very I know it's out in the air so
you can talk that we even talked about
it yeah so we're gonna have the game
spot stage in our usual spot in the the
ceph hole in the LA Convention Center
you guys going to be right beside us
yeah Your Honor the stage as well what
do you guys gonna be doing because
people kind of know what we do yeah demo
games like all the games that are
intensity three games that we already
know about that are going to be playable
for the first gem there we're going to
be playing on our stage so what are you
guys going to be doing what did we
decided to do because this is a like a
new III like experience for you guys all
right yeah you figure for eight years
basically we've done what you're doing
yeah it's so now to be off their the way
we do is we're going to keep doing what
we already do over on kind of funny
right which of course youtube.com slash
kind of funny kinda funny games and all
that jazz um the the thing about their
right is that we interpret the news with
our audience and what you know I means
we're bringing on our friends from the
industry developers will be coming on
with us but they'll be coming on more to
talk about what's happening are they
excited by VR what's happening here not
so much to talk about their game
specifically not to show you a demo but
to talk about what's the best thing
they've seen so far if they haven't seen
anything we're giving them passes and
sending them out to go see games and
come back and report on what they think
of it such like that you're just going
to have random celebrity people be your
journalist exactly yes go at it's about
time they did something for us you know
I mean that's a good point yeah get
devon Sawa to go play black ops 3 exam
back exactly what's noticed someone I
was wondering what devon Sawa think yeah
like I'm we're gonna find out what does
Casper think of black ops 3 damned if
kind of player figure it out I think a
couple thousand more people now are
demanding yeah I think said yeah wake it
up yeah the way we look at it is that
you know you guys do what you do well
and so like why try to compete with that
that's the whole metro kinda funny
anyway is that we're not you know when I
we were at gen we would break news that
break news and talk to sources all that
kinds of a now just like well things
happen like you guys are talking about
with Konami and getting interpret it so
yeah but what's fun about this e3 thing
is yeah we can have Harley from Epic
Meal Time for instance be like what you
think about alienation I'm Peoria's like
what we have I'm played Ian rival here's
a pass new google play it that's been
back in 20 minutes let us stop we're
bringing in Freddie Wong of course
Freddie's a good friend of ours and he
was before he got internet famous a
world champion guitar hero players oh
really I want him to go play all the
music games and come back and tell us
what he thinks of itself with that world
champion yeah oh my god you look it up
look at use this thing sometimes I can
use your nice bro
ghana god damn it yeah that is a total
for all you do what do you do is it
lights the side of my face oh that's why
i have it on bright all the time okay
like that like are you looking forward
to this year's e3 because one of the
thing one of the things this sort of
happens when you're covering the game so
much is that getting out there and
actually trying to like play games and
actually trying to get in the show floor
and I talk people and meet people do you
think you'll have sort of more of an
ability to do that this year now you're
going to just leave let you're not gonna
leave like making Tim on the stage for a
while you guys do this quite indeed we
left Nick and Tim alone on a stream once
during GDC right we did our stream every
day for eight hours we had all these
developers come in and stuff over on
twitchtv kind of funny games and we left
them alone literally once for literally
five minutes and they started talking
about pubes right away right so no they
cannot be left alone women in III
audience to figure out what's going on
Portillo goin uh we're not gonna talk no
he's gonna be that'd be really hard to
walk with you the videos a little
misleading then in that case I think we
better have yang port solo all right
full disclosure he's gonna get that was
part of the contract we didn't read with
you sitting in a hotel room yeah exactly
portillos got the after-hours coverage
lockdown yeah course yeah and come into
the LA Zoo brandy snifters coat yeah
laughter Burke what are you guys looking
forward to at e3 because we're now
getting into the stage we're sort of all
the games that are coming out except for
the witcher 3 are kind of like yeah have
happened that we'd broken age today and
it's gonna be that like little couple of
weeks where we're going towards III
where all the rumors start to happen we
already mentioned fallout 4 in the
trailer but that's the one yeah right
that's the way that was a joke we did at
the end that thing as an ad lib but I
mean really like fallout what is going
on fall for clearance a rollup a long
time in form because announcer their
conference will be announced and come
out this year and and I we thought
mothers actually maybe even last time
around the show uh so I think that's the
begin what I get it so excited about is
you know cuz we have exhibitor badges
were able to get to the forum before
during the conference's is all the
placards with tape over them and all the
the the curtains over yes for games that
are unannounced that's kind of the stuff
that's most exciting to me and hoping my
number nines there so I can play it
again dodging the forklifts and pallets
yeah people kind of looking at you like
shall we be here not sure about these
people to be here but me no buts
yeah and everyone's got periscope you
know what if someone's just gonna bundle
their way into the Moscow or as an Intel
a convention center and just be like
someone dating someone someone maybe me
oh look it's that time I pretended I was
in fallout 4 on the beach you do a lot
of cool stuff yeah that was real fun
that was like five in the morning that's
how I plan for fallout 4 yeah and I
think you're there's been some like
rumors about you know if the things
they're having like their own conference
but what else could they possibly talk
about yeah was it too yes honored yes or
dishonor and doom okay yep but yeah it's
got a but it's gotta be for me I think I
think it's all just everything's aligned
to where they can announce you know for
me this year maybe the doom beta and all
that kind of stuff and that's coming out
maybe you know maybe something with a
prayer Bible and obviously dishonored so
I'd there things to announce but um yeah
I just feel like they have nothing to
gain by really announcing the game and
waiting a year they have nothing again
fought for will sell millions and
millions of copies if they stay today
it's ready and here it is it doesn't
matter so I think they know that any
Todd Howard knows that I think Pete
Hines knows that I think everyone over
there knows that and so they'll I think
they'll announce it'll come out probably
November and that Sunday night like III
does even started by the time we're
gonna do an event Bethesda still take
away Minute of everyone's sailors
immediately and it's not unprecedented
it would be okay maybe that time frame
would be unprecedented but they met
Skyrim into vgx Azure vijay awards and
that was only in the december prior so
like they messed with in 12 works as
well as yet and then they did a very
similar thing where we went you know
that at that time the next year like
april we went to utah to play the game
and then they kind of went quiet again
and then they just they released the
game so i knew people gonna buy the game
and i have every expectation to be
awesome so it's it's um it's something
we've been waiting a long time for you
know media i kind of immersive you like
world forward with the witcher 3 where
imminently it's going to be funny 3 i
think like last year people were kind of
hoping okay let's get the whole spread
of like new IP new new sort of
announcement games that really look like
they're like taking hold of the
current-gen consoles we kind of didn't
regain it what we wanted i feel like
this year is the year like some of those
console we're gonna have to get like
some nice big fancy my only fear right
is that instead of getting the nice big
games and things
this is why you bought these next-gen
systems it's going to be hey here's
Morpheus and here's more vr stuff in
this really stop you notified of your
i'm a fan enough but i don't think it's
gonna be super successful yeah i don't
want him to wait bernal press conference
talking about it or basic own I think I
mean I told the story before about how
when I first played oculus I played eval
curry this is several years ago at e3
and I'd been two hours like this will be
like maybe mine either tempe drive no
idea this one but this was the first
time at e3 was like I want can i play
that again what can I do that again and
you know I wasn't a believer until I
played it and then I was like wow this
is going to be revolutionary but I think
there's a lot of commercial realities
that are gonna make it hard for instance
you need to have a beautiful several
thousand dollar rig to be able to play
oculus you need to have a playstation 4
to play Morpheus when the be on when the
processing is on board one of these
devices then I think that it'll be more
revolutionary when it sticks into a
television on its own bread like I mean
I'll be expensive it's me far-flung and
who knows when that's gonna happen but
since you need another piece of hardware
like that's that's gonna stop while
people from enjoying yeah i mean we're
looking at all the you know stuff right
now with morpheus right it's just like I
feel like we're repeating the sins of
the past with move yeah like you're
gonna introduce this in your alright
this is a you know the pie chart of
PlayStation 4 owners this is the number
of people who got it this is the number
of people who are gonna actually want to
play games every so often so developers
don't make games for it so it doesn't go
anywhere so it just fails yeah same kind
of experience that like you can watch
people doing it on TV but you're never
gonna get anything approaching the
experience of actually playing that like
you look you walk watch like a sick
fallout 4 demo you've got a great idea
of what's going on your a hype for that
like because they're seeing it but with
move and then with VR it doesn't show
well to someone watching a live stream
or watching a show so an how do you sell
to that Pete person it's the Nintendo
3ds problem i think and take it on the
road it on this pioneer in the country
or the thing happen with the wii when
they started shopping that around but at
least the thing with the wii was it was
a kind of a mass-market piece of
hardware whereas this is all obvious
it's like a niche within and yet already
hey by this 400 our system and then buy
this piece of equip which is probably
gonna be worth like 250 and then x games
for it yeah the other thing well you
know you need more boys champions will
be free for like that that i can I move
on cuz looking for Brad yeah what are
used we tried to believe
the UH the thing with the with weave
with the Wemo and and movie was that
their lease tactile and you can actually
early see the game I mean to your point
like you can actually show anyone even
the footage so yeah it's all this is
what it looks like in here Z you can
play it it's like we can't even show you
what it looks like because it's not
possible so you need to actually put the
headset on and see we developer country
want to show the game they'd work on
their super excited about their like
it's VR and but your audience I know
can't look at that soul displayed on
mouse keyboard oh really is like alright
cool this is cool then they put the
heads off this is even cooler yeah but
it's like yeah how do you drive that
point home to somebody and then
developers as well when they're making
them are probably going to have be
making games that can at least fall back
to Madison keyboard no because otherwise
they pigeonhole themselves it's going to
be funny 3 i'm looking forward to it
hopefully we'll have a bunch of
announcements on the software front
perhaps on the hardware phone as well
and if we don't we can all just hang
around we're gonna have fun no matter
what coming good time yeah yeah
absolutely we're gonna what you say
music sighs my girlfriend my girlfriend
is very excited for devan's 00 upper 20
girls like guys girls really really
excited all the girls are excited for
devin and all the guys excited Cisco
we're gonna get down me and my buddy and
the back in waterford we were like 13
years old we bought single copies of the
tongue song because it came with an mp4
of the video Oh which if you're a
thirteen-year-old boy is quite a good
but you want you wanted to see those
dumps like a truck I did I want to see
that power all the bosses turn up from
all the various cities in America their
bosses turn up from Washington and LA
these poor lady has been on a bus for or
there back in my day we gonna do
anything they wanted a party in there
they ramped up there we go receipt they
go there anyway my goodness if you're
probably ninety percent of you might not
remember the thong song as well as we do
let's just go and he's excited to come
to e3 he is yet and his his lovely
finger glove better bring mostly finger
going on with all right that's enough of
that then i guess i watch the phone
selling it for if you want to watch the
Tom song you can go to what was this
kind of twitch TV for such kind of funny
money that you guys just lose good info
all the time yeah exactly you're not
what we are here we wrong song you're
playing on to it hmm Greg Danny hi gran
what's going on
thank you I'll see you guys and I'm up
actually no i'll see you guys tomorrow
right no yeah we probably promoted that
yeah tomorrow he's gonna be on twitch.tv
/ kind of funny games talking about that
their game news I'm calling me Greg lime
just like we do every day 11am over on
twitch TV and then you're gonna stick
around do the kind of funny games cast
with yes which will be at the following
week right yep exactly if you're Patrian
subscribers patreon.com such kind of
funny games do get enough friday get it
earlier yeah oh my god it's how you
doing what addy what a DI of you yeah
fiscally irresponsible not to go to
patreon.com/scishow egames throws a buck
or two but of course he actually have
nothing at five to get the mp3 hand from
video they'll be an exclusive games cast
with roger craig smith the voice of
sonic that'll be going up here couple
days the voice of Sonic yeah it is here
and at sea oh yeah i did already if
batman arkham origins oh my god a bunch
of nerdy anime crap i don't know you
just happened in America you had me at
Sonic okay he's gotta go fast have you
ever heard that about what Sonic's
favorite famous love ya gotta go fast
gotta go fast gamma alright let's wrap
this up I'll see you guys tomorrow
alright thanks ray what's come on kind
of funny gamespot live at e3 2015 check
it out thanks very much everyone for
watching in the lobby today thanks his
team schaefer coming on and thanks to
peter bran and of course Chris waters as
ever my friend I know you're just not
gonna oh you're welcome there you go I
thought was gonna sorry crystal got
really what he is you just saw me back
Mary Kish ty roots probably responsible
for that tongue song bit I'm gonna go
into limp for Eric T and I'm horik thank
yep all right got it art am thorac
thanks very much in the back and thanks
every for watching we'll see you guys
next week adios